If deep time is incomprehensible,
how does the human brain understand the deep time over which it is now believed to have evolved?
This is a tricky question, you've got to read
this a couple times before you understand
what it means. Basically Darwin asks us
to imagine that human beings along with
other animals and plants emerged over deep time.
That over millions and millions of years
human beings changed from
essentially apes and monkeys
into the people that we have today.
The human brain is therefore
not just a product of evolution.
But it is a product of deep time.
How does the brain understand the deep time
over which it is believed to have evolved.
So this also requires conceptualization.
People had been thinking about the brain
for several hundred years.
This is an example of how you can look at
different kinds of brains.
Over the course of the 18th century.
So comparing brains thinking about brains.
This idea is not new.
But what you have in the 19th century
is the first effort to understand the human brain
in geological terms
as the product of deep time.
So they imagine that there's a lower part of the brain
that is very very primitive.
And it can only understand space in terms of time.
That is it takes me three days to walk to Menlo Park.
That is how far Menlo Park is from here.
It takes me three days to walk there.
That's the primitive part of the brain,
so they think in the 19th century.
Over time the higher parts of the brain
like geological strata accreting
begin to get deposited in the human mind.
Leading to our modern advanced brains.
How do we know they're modern and advanced?
Is that we can imagine time in terms of space.
We have things like clocks
that help us to see time in spatial terms.
And this is a sign of how advanced we are.
So the human brain begins to be imagined
like a geological stratum in the 19th century
that it's strata like rocks are layered through time.
Now let me show you how that idea has crept
into our way of thinking and talking today
in ways that we didn't even know
Many of us, all of you in this room, have certainly
used the term the stream of consciousness.
And you have probably used it without understanding
the origins of this term.
Well it emerges from the deep time revolution
in the writing of the psychologist William James
who studied with geologist Louis Agassiz at Harvard.
He was very influenced by this
new deep time way of thinking.
Not just about the earth as layered strata,
but about the human brain as layered strata.
He tried to explain how you could understand the flow of human thought as a kind of geological process.
So he asks you to imagine
saying in this sentence:
"the pack of cards is on the table."
This is gonna bring back traumatic memories of diagramming sentences in seventh grade.
So I'm sorry because it brought those back for me.
Sorry Mrs. Collie, I didn't like diagramming sentences.
But William James is asking us to imagine,
and I actually I brought a prop so here look at this.
The pack of cards is on the table.
And he's asking you to diagram what the brain is doing
as it is thinking that thought.
And he calls this the stream of consciousness.
Here's what he's imagining.
Remember the X-Y axis I showed you earlier in the talk?
This is exactly what he's doing.
He's imagining you saying this sentence:
"The pack of cards is on the table."
And the 1 2 3 and 4 is not grammatical right?
It's just like time. Time is happening: 1-2-3-4.
And then he has this y-axis this spatial dimension.
And what the space is,
is not a kind of geological stratum.
But it is what he calls the fullness of thought.
So as you're saying the sentence,
and as you're thinking it
your mind is getting fuller and fuller and fuller
of the thought of the pack of cards being on the table.
So that at the end of the sentence
you're way up high with your thinking
about the pack of cards being on the table.
Now what's interesting about this is that he says
if you put a knife through the center of the thought—
imagine doing that, put a knife
through the center of the thought.
You would find it suffused with the whole of all
of the rest of the thought.
Just like a knife cutting through the strata of the rocks
that I have been showing you
would show you cutting through all
of the strata of the earth.
So when you use the term the stream of consciousness
he means a stream in the literal
geological sense of the term.
That our brains have thoughts
running through them like streams
that erode through our minds and that
we can diagram them like a geological stratum.